tiffany is with us in new york
hi tiffany how are you hi thank you so
much for taking my call
sure what's up so
i've been dating a guy for about three
months and
last night we were hanging out and he
dropped that he plans on
spending about 525
on a psychic um
i immediately felt uncomfortable i told
him that
i thought it was a silly idea i would
kind of like talk through it a bit as to
why he
felt like this person what this person
could do for him
but you know things have been going well
up into this up till this point
but definitely i think i i've been doing
the babysit steps for almost two years i
started with seventy thousand dollars of
debt i'm down to about twelve thousand
so i'm on the tail end of my journey and
so uh hearing that definitely you know
perked my ears and made me nervous
so i guess i'm wondering like what is it
that makes you nervous
the 525 or the psychic
both i mean also just
now when you put the two things together
it gets like really nervous is that what
you're saying
exactly thinking that he could be
irresponsible with money
and thinking about you know future
casting i think i had a flash forward to
five years from now oh my gosh like if i
marry this guy is he gonna
yeah tiffany how long have you dated
this guy because she said three months
didn't you yeah three months okay yeah
well she started off with long term and
then said three months
well that's that's cool so um okay so
how can we help i guess my
uh you know i kind of thought uh
been hit with this a lot in the early
dating you know i'm a single woman in
new york city and i guess i wonder what
are the
filters in terms of money because i
found myself thinking oh are we not
financially compatible
yeah um well i mean there's two issues
yeah there's two issues number one
having talked with uh
a lot of the single ladies that work on
our team here
and you know there's i get to hear some
very interesting conversations over here
some very interesting conversations in
tennessee we call it
slim pickens there's not a lot of good
ones out there to pick from
right and uh this guy has kind of proven
this uh theory to be true
um so i i you know the 525 dollars
if he were spending it on something else
doesn't necessarily scare me
uh but you called me and chris and we're
people of faith and so
we think psychics are funny um
i am also a person of faith and i think
psychics are funny you're not
a respecter of that methodology yeah
that's a lot of money to spend on voodoo
um so yeah
um what have you talked to him about
your financial goals has he told you
what his are
um i'm not super clear on what his are
but i mean you know how it is when you
get
into this journey you can't help but
talk about it all the time so yeah he
knows my goals
how old are you guys i'm 29.
okay all right i i've got a uh
my daughters are slightly older than you
my son's about your age
um the only way i know how to answer
this is papa dave and i
has nothing to do with financial really
it's the your values
are not aligned you believe different
things
and that's more important than the 525
dollars the 525 dollars
is an exceptional amount of money to
spend on something where your values
aren't aligned so it
really caused you to go
but um you know the the if you were one
of my kids and we're having a cup of
coffee i would just go
this guy's not the one and the reason is
is that if you can't agree on spiritual
things if you can't agree on money you
can't agree on kids and you can't agree
on in-laws
those are the four things that break
everybody up
later on as you said i fast forward and
now he's spending 5000 with the psychic
because she's now our marriage counselor
and that's that's what you're fast
forwarding yourself into so i'm just
that's just papa dave saying you don't
have the same set of values
now if you both were into psychics i
guess you could go forward but
the fact that one of you is not into
that then
that's going to be a deal breaker you
you got to be aligned on the important
things in religion
is one of them yeah tiffany run
don't don't don't stroll away i want you
to treat this like debt and run
yeah yeah okay yeah you're you're gonna
be okay honey just
just when as you meet the next one
here's the thing find out crazy early
and then avoid it
here's what's interesting okay you put
your money towards what's important to
you
yeah and so if you put a lot of money
towards something it says it's very
important to you
so this guy's not like a recreational
psychic guy
he's in deep recreational psychic is a
50
drive by for kicks at some fair or
something right
or a 25 let's see what the palm reader
says ha ha ha
that's like a recreational gambler but
this guy dropped
525 on a blackjack table and you don't
believe in gambling
it get that's what got your attention
there was enough money that it's like
wow
and uh so there's there is a one-two
punch here yeah that's a really good
conversation she said that dollar amount
my wallet twitched
in my pocket yeah well that's cause your
wallet's pretty tight
you're just tight you're a tight one
but that's i mean you're friendly you
you have to look at that and you say
that is a red flag
right again it it what we were talking
about coming in
to the to the opening of the show today
is that your values
there is an integrated thing here and so
sometimes people say well dave i'll take
dave ramsey but without the religion
well then it wouldn't be dave ramsey
because i truly believe that
what you believe causes you to handle
money
a certain way and so as a person of
faith when i believe that the borrower
is truly slave to the lender
then that causes a separate set of
actions reactions and attitudes yes
and to the extent i'm not aligned with
someone on that then i can't be in a
deal with them that's right